hello and welcome everyone to today's
brilliant minds bold questions virtual
talk
our series spotlights high impact
research from across the academy from
computer science population and public
health economics and robotics
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
global research organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity
my name is rachel parker i'm senior
director of research at cfar and it is
my distinct pleasure to introduce you
to goldie najat and amis ahavi two
fellows in our program on innovation
equity and the future of prosperity
amis is associate director of the iep
program and a political scientist at the
university of tel aviv interested in the
social aspects of innovation policy and
comparative social policy
goldie is a professor of mechanical
engineering at the university of toronto
where she's also a canada research chair
in robots and society
before we begin today's session will
last approximately 30 minutes i will be
taking advantage of my position as chair
today to ask our speakers the first
question before opening it up to
questions from participants online
if you have a question you can use the q
a function to submit one we ask that you
not use the chat to submit questions
lastly this session is being recorded
and will be available on the cfar
website next week
thank you so much for joining goldie and
amos
thanks so much for having us
um so together you were both awarded a
manulife seafarer population health
brand for a project on innovating for
social needs in an era of social
isolation i wondered if you could each
start by telling us about your
collaborative research on socially
assisted robots
sure
so yeah we were very lucky to get the
cfar slash manual life funding which
allowed us to really look at how
governments long-term care facilities um
or even other healthcare facilities are
using this technology socially assisted
robots to help them during the pandemic
and we were looking at you know their
uses at the low level deployment even at
government level to see if there was any
actions taken to help use this
technology and we had you know
interviews luckily we had interviews in
both israel and canada with
different government players at the
federal at provincial level even
municipal level and non-per non
non-for-profits
as well as long-term care facilities um
administrators and staff and and in
canada here what we did was we actually
had one of our robots deployed in a
long-term care home
uh where the robot interacted with staff
directly to get their inputs and
feedback of using the technology and it
was for the purpose of covet screening
we've all had to do copic screening the
last two years um when we go into a
health care facility especially um so we
had automation really poised for that
scenario where it was screening the
staff members coming in for their shifts
and allowing them to go in checking
their mass and so on so we we really got
great feedback from this research
project and it was the first
collaboration between for myself
especially as a roboticist i'm working
with amos from the political science
side so it was great to see both aspects
come to life
um
and for me it was also the first
collaboration with a robotics engineer
and
of course when you uh
see what the robots can do you think
well obviously this is something
that different long-term care facilities
truly need especially in an era like a
pandemic where you have major workforce
shortages
in the facilities
you need
aids
to of workers very dedicated care
workers and these facilities and we know
thanks to the work of goldie and others
that robots that do at least some of
these are very important tasks
uh but then when we actually go down
and try to see what's happening
in the facilities themselves what we
find is in many of these places we
certainly need help
they do have some idea that robots could
help them
but they don't know really how they
don't know how to what type of robots
how to access them
and um
often it's also not all that affordable
at least they don't think that these
robots are affordable and then we uh
start asking questions and these are the
questions that very int very much
interest myself and my students
questions about policy
how could governments step in and help
the different facilities uh bring in the
robots incorporate them into the work
done in the facilities
especially under these extreme
conditions of a pandemic
so following up on that last point um
i
i guess there's there's a question that
again could be for both of you uh in
terms of what are the barriers to
deploying robots both on the on the
technical side but also on the political
side
yeah so from the technical side i mean
there's still things to be done uh if
you want to deploy robots to be able to
be autonomous in these kind of
environments you're looking at you know
safe navigation through hallways and in
residence rooms and so on so
human-centered environments robots
knowing things from social skills like
how do you navigate when there's other
people in the hallway you know passing
um on the standing on the right letting
people pass you on the left and so on
things things that you know we take for
granted when we're when we're navigating
ourselves or walking through hallways
and then there's of course um a
challenge with older adults
we're promoting
natural communication with these robots
so social assistive robots provide
assistance in a non-contact way so they
they interact with people the same way
we interact with each other so through
you know verbal communication or
non-verbal communication and so
speech recognition becomes a huge
element of these robots and uh it's
challenging uh looking at different user
groups and trying to understand their
speech so for robots there's been some
you know some challenges in speech
recognition for this population you know
especially we're looking at people
living with dementia being able to
understand their intent is really
important so that's been a challenge
that we've been trying to address and
develop better speech recognition to
target this population there's also of
course privacy and ethical issues um you
know robot ethics is a brand new
research area that we've been looking
into and how to you know properly design
these robots and deploy them so that you
know people feel comfortable with them
they feel safe privacy
is you know protected when needed
especially because we're dealing with a
vulnerable population so now in robotics
in robotics we're looking at you know
things like encrypting encryption of
information and things like that we've
never had to deal with before but since
we're sending information through the
internet right um especially private
medical information that may be
so looking at how do you make sure the
information is secure
and then of course from a training point
of view as amis was mentioning you know
people working in these fields don't
necessarily know what the advantages or
benefits of using robots are to their
work to decreasing their workload um to
improving their own quality of life not
just the residents themselves but the
staff right so the training that goes
into deploying the robots in their homes
making it easier for them and the
education that comes along with the use
of the robots has really helped us with
the uptake of this technology which i
think is really important
um i'll
talk for a moment about
about barriers in terms of government
intervention uh the first question for
government really is are robots the
proper appropriate response right
so there will be questions about um
would robots really help and who would
they help
uh because obviously uh we're always
going to be different pressure groups
that are going to lobby government and
say you know robots
that's uh that's the future uh there's
going to be better services and this is
also going to develop markets for uh
entire national economy and so on so
forth
but is it really true and uh for
government
much of this
is pressure groups pushing in different
directions
and uh government has to sift through
the different arguments and determine uh
what is more credible and what is less
so perhaps
uh the right uh response would not be
robots at all perhaps it's going to be
something more to do uh with uh
subsidizing workers or something like
that uh a different uh questions even if
you decide that robots should be at
least part
of the policy response
to the crisis in nursing homes for
example
what should you do
what are the instruments that you can
use
to
actually uh help disseminate the robots
so uh goldie uh a moment before
mentioned training
who's gonna do the training
so you might uh from the government's
perspective say well this is not our
problem training is something that is
going to be uh conducted say by the
firms distributing the robots
they have a financial interest in doing
so and it might be true
but for different reasons uh once you
actually survey the market this might
not be happening especially during
pandemic times so maybe government does
have to
step in and then that actually means but
government has to uh scope what is
happening on the ground before it makes
these types of decisions
uh who are you going to subsidize if
you're going to subsidize anybody is it
going to be the robotic firms developing
robots or universities perhaps it's just
going to be the purchase
of existing robots
should you help in adapting the robots
there are also questions uh
goldy mentioned privacy also about
regulation new technology also means new
challenges in terms of regulation so
there are a lot of difficult questions
that governments must answer when they
decide to move in into this new policy
area
somewhat of a follow-up but maybe uh
taking us in a bit of a different
direction
amish i think this question is for you
um you know i can imagine a world in
which some people would be thrilled by
the vision of robots taking care of the
elderly for example but others i suspect
might find that um a frightening
prospect do you think that uh patients
nursing home residents etc uh would be
willing to accept health care services
administered by a robot and how do we
how do we in canada compare this in
respect to other publics across the
world in israel for example from your
studies um i suspect that goldie uh
probably knows more about this actually
than i do but i'll give it a stat
nonetheless
now
what i would argue is that we already
know something for quite some time uh in
the world of research about technology
acceptance
and what shapes technology acceptance
actually it goes back to uh different
studies i think it was davis who
initiated this uh area of research back
in the end of the 1980s
and he formulated of a technology
acceptance model why do people decide
that the technology is for them or not
uh one reason is because of the
technology is perceived as useful
is it a useful technology or not
and from our interviews uh with uh
different stakeholders in the system it
seems that most of them are quite
convinced now that robotics certainly
has a whole lot of potential to help
them a lot so at least from the
perspective
this is not the patients i know but the
facility managers
uh certainly robots are something that
they would like to have uh getting them
into the facilities
as goldie can attest is a whole
different matter that's more complicated
but at least they would like to have
uh these uh robots because they think
they might be useful
um it might also be true of many of the
residents patients and the health care
system that robots could help them
and we also know uh from research that
one of the most important
factors
that shape people's preferences in terms
of technology in general and robotics
specifically
um is that they are to some extent
already familiar with similar
technologies so if they already have
experience with similar technologies the
likelihood that they would be uh
accepting of new technologies increases
um now this of course uh leads to the
question
if we're not if we're talking for
example about the elderly
that as we know uh
quite often have less
past experience with technologies than
the younger generations
what happens then
uh then there are other factors that
matter quite a lot there's about ease of
use how easy is it to use the technology
and the good news is that uh robotic
developers like goldie here
know that this is a vital competent
of robotics
robotics doesn't help if you can't use
it
and so it's really important that uh
robotics would be accessible
and i'll end with uh
international comparison
um
is canada more accepting less exp
accepting to be in other places i really
can't say but from a few studies that
have actually systematically compared uh
acceptance of new technologies and
robots across
cross countries what uh the researchers
have found but cultural differences
actually are less important than we
might think but everybody thinks that in
japan people you know are robotics
crazed they love robots and all that but
it seems that um if you ask them the
same questions the differences between
americans and the japanese are not that
great
uh it many times really boils down to do
they have past experience with similar
technologies
uh is it going to be useful
and uh is it easy to use uh goldie
sure yeah so we've been doing research
in this for now close to 20 years so
we've we've deployed our robots and
long-term care facilities health care
facilities you name it and we've done
hundreds upon hundreds of human robot
interaction studies and and really
what's important here is are you
developing a technology that meets the
needs and wants of the user groups
whether you know it's the healthcare
workers themselves or the residents or
patients in the hospital that's really
important um
is it obvious to them what the benefits
are that's another aspect that it has to
be clear to them what is this robot
coming in here for and how will it
support my needs i think that's really
important so functionality also matching
appearance of robots we've seen robots
you know from humanoids or androids with
artificial skin all the way down to
mobile platforms or even pet-like robots
right so there's a huge spectrum of
different embodiments for robots and the
important thing here is you know does
that functionality that we're developing
match the appearance of the robot so you
know if you want a robot to assist a
health care worker or it may be or a
resident you know does it meet the needs
can it move in the environment does it
have hands to pick up objects to you
know supporting for example feeding a
person or you know monitoring a person
does it have that embodiment that's
really important number one i think um
and the intent to use it future intent
to use the technology so you really have
to deploy the robots have people
interact with them you can't have people
look at robots from afar and a lot of
studies had initially started like that
because you know there wasn't that many
people developing robots especially for
the healthcare sector
so now you can deploy them in the homes
have people interact with them
understand the technology its
capabilities and we found that that
really helps with uptake of the
technology and their acceptance of the
technology itself in terms of experience
with technology um you know we do you
know think of the older cohort right now
may not have as much experience like our
age groups have ranged from 65 to our
oldest participant was 110 years old
almost knock on wood right so um you
know their experience has you know
generally within that group even is is
very diverse
but i think it's the idea especially of
socially assisted robots that they are
they're natural in their communication
and interaction
capabilities so there's no
knowledge that has to be gained to use
the technology because you interact with
the robot the same way you would
interact with a person
and we found that that's important and
of course the generations to come will
be easier and easier when we get to the
gaming generation right so um i think
that's important uh it's it's important
to pre you know to present the
technology make sure that people
understand what its needs and wants are
and you're matching the needs and wants
of the users
and you know you deploy it so that they
can understand
why they need it why it has long-term
benefits which is another thing a lot of
studies have been short-term you take
probably you know you were discussing
you know pilot studies are only for a
certain number of months and then the
robots are taken out and then it's kind
of what's going to happen next right
so we need to make sure that we ensure
that we have this long-term deployment
to gain the benefits of using the
technology and the technology needs to
adapt to people in the field so that's
why the intelligence of a robot is
really important and brings together
this ai and robotics together why
these two fields coming together
actually
improve our technology deployment
so there's a there's a question
that that's come in um we typically
think about
robotics automation as
a threat uh to jobs and job security uh
but this person wants to know how can
robots help us with the emerging hr
um or healthcare hr crisis
[Music]
so
it's um this is a really important
question
uh what is quite clear uh is that
actually both things might be true that
robots could be a threat
in terms of a workforce but it could
also help with uh the
problem that we have shortages
uh we have major shortages now in uh
in the healthcare sector uh generally uh
more specifically when we look at
long-term care uh we have major problems
over there could robots help definitely
they could help and they do
so if you think about uh what the
healthcare workers that are in the
system of the care workers broader in
the system in residential care are doing
um but robots complement them so uh for
example and i'm sure uh goldie has many
more examples than i can offer she has
so many years of experience doing this
but you're thinking about cleaning
disinfecting these are things that have
to be done on a daily basis
and all these types of facilities now
the workers have to do many different
things there are less verb workers than
our than there used to be at the
beginning of crisis simply because
workers have left the system many of
them have burnt out and then it's really
important that whatever could be done by
a robot be done by a robot so the
robot's clean they disinfect they can
bring the new linen uh to the beds so on
so forth uh this really helps we can
also make of attacks
of of care workers much less strenuous
because a lot of what is being done by
the care workers let's face it uh our
tedious task very hard task so if you
think for instance about
um you have to
uh take a patient in a bed he's
bedridden she's bedridden and turn her
over um that could be quite hard if you
have to lift her backs even harder
lifting a grown person is hard and then
if you have robotic echo skeleton echo
skeletons that do the work for you
that's a major boon that's a major help
that means that
those who are doing the work the workers
in the system who are doing work it
makes their work so much easier it also
frees time for them it relieves them of
these casts so they can do
other things that robots at least for
now uh really can't do very well so
one-on-one interactions
uh with residents with patients it frees
up time for doing that and we all know
how important that is so certainly uh
robots
could help be already due and hopefully
uh this is going to expand
yeah maybe i can just add to that robots
are great at doing the 3ds dirty dull
and dangerous jobs so if you think about
that um you know as amos was saying
there's a lot of repetitive work
um for caregivers to do and robots can
take care of those repetitive jobs they
can do it with a smile on their face you
know so they can so for example
recreational activities that sometimes
you know when when there's a lot of
tasks for caregivers to do those are put
kind of down on the priority list and so
there's not as much engagement with the
the residents and cognitive engagement
as we all know and social engagement is
really important to residents living in
long-term care homes especially you know
for overall moods
minimizing depression as well as helping
with dementia right interventions are
really important with that so if robots
could facilitate you know activities
memory activities whatever it may be
um with the group and they can do that
you know throughout the course of a day
rather than just having it one time
a day for you know whatever number of
days but they could do it every day for
a certain number of hours it really
would help with you know on the on the
resident's side with their overall
well-being and health as well as the
staff side because you know they're not
jumping from activity to activity so
they can focus on the higher skill tasks
because we can't say robots are going to
take over all the tasks that humans do
um that's not in close to our future
right now the idea is that they can
supplement and support the caregivers
and it helps reduce the stress and
workload they have especially during the
pandemic right so a lot of activities
have been cut out you know external
people that used to come in to help with
these activities can no longer come in
especially family members like eating
was a huge um
activity that you know you do it of
course for health and nutrition benefits
but if you think about it
usually healthcare
sorry eating you know family members
would come in and help support the
residents to do that but they weren't
allowed anymore into the homes so then
how did the staff get the support to
feed all these individuals at one time
during one hour period for a meal
so this is where robotics can really
help with automation
a follow-up on that point um
when you think about the types of roles
that that robots are moving into in a
care home um
or other kind of medicalized um
setting is it important for them to then
be intelligent and and if so how are
they intelligent
that's a perfect question so we believe
that robots have to be adaptive to
people and that requires them to be
intelligent so no two people are alike
and no two people you know living with
dementia have similar um needs right so
everybody's different so we need to be
able to personalize the interaction so
we focus on person person-centered care
which we think is important so the
robots have to be able to understand
your level of cognition your
capabilities in terms of speech and even
non-verbal communication and then
respond accordingly and to do that they
take a lot of information so they have
training they need to train their
adaptability so they have learning
models and so on right so that's why
it's really important because you don't
also want a robot there's a difference
between you know automation in the sense
of doing the same task over and over
again automatically and then autonomy
which allows flexibility to adapt to new
situations and new people so that's
where we're pushing the envelope we feel
like you know the robots that can be
intelligent and be self-aware of their
scenario and their environment and the
people in them will have more long-term
use because if you just have a robot do
one simple task with one specific you
know behavior the uptake and the
prolonged use of that you know it's like
you know you get sick of a technology
you get bored of it because you can't do
anything else and then you put it aside
right and we definitely don't want that
with our robotics because we're we're
focusing on helping people so yeah so
that's how they become intelligent being
able to personalize and adapt and
sometimes even persuade people to do
tasks that they don't want to do right
like take your medication right or
remember to eat which are really crucial
to your overall well-being
thanks goldie um i think we have time
for about one more question
um and this one is
uh about the kind of
evolution i think not only in in
robotics but also in uh in a.i and and
wondering what role robots will play
in diagnosing an illness uh and and kind
of how ai might be leveraged in this
capacity if at all and you know are
people working at kind of at that
particular interface
that's a great question and there's been
a lot of i think
advancements in this area especially
with covid we we actually designed a
cova detection system which was all ai
based in in terms of detecting what
symptoms you had in a non-contact way to
determine preliminary if you had covid
right so you would go for you know more
in-depth screening let's say so that is
an important fact if you think about
deployment like again in the same idea
that we were talking about the robots
doing the screening
instead of asking the screening
questions the robots just through
interaction you know through your cough
or your sniffling um or your breathing
right or your temperature can detect if
you have covid or preliminary detect
that you have covet and you know kind of
send that alert that's needed to you as
well as uh the health your health care
professionals right for support so
that's really important um they've been
used to diagnose different types of
cancers so the great thing about these
algorithms is we can feed them a lot of
information and and they can learn to be
able to detect the features right for
each type of virus or our disease and
then help us to better diagnose um in
the future and be able to decipher
between different types of diseases you
know how the progression of the disease
and so on even through time so that's
opened up a whole new field in health
care for us
this is exciting uh to think about maybe
uh a bit
a bit unnerving at the same time but
it's it's uh exciting to think about
what the future might bring
um
uh i wonder if amos you had any final
thoughts in thinking about um privacy
and ethics you know as as they relate to
this sort of frontier area that you and
goldie have been exploring
well uh-huh i'll be very brief i don't
have too much time to elaborate
but obviously there are concerns about
privacy about
use and who owns proprietary information
that is
basically collected
by the robots
is it of a company that produces the
robots is it facility managers
should the people the patients for
residents
should they have a say in how that
information is used
i for once certainly wouldn't want
information about say my mental health
state uh to be of the propriety
knowledge of a large firmware that can
sell it
to uh different uh other firms
uh that might be interested in it uh so
these are questions tough questions that
uh we should certainly address i would
also like to mention very quickly but
there are also questions about
the rights of the workers in all of this
workers are also very concerned about
robot surveillance
which is something that
is not just
could happen it actually does happen it
came up at least in one of the
interviews we conducted in israel
that robots are used
to monitor control workers
and these are questions that we as a
public
should be interested in uh this is a new
area and a new area needs new rules
thank you so much for raising that
really important issue um and thank you
both for taking the time to speak with
us i've certainly learned a lot and
looking forward to watching what comes
from from your collaboration thanks
again
thank you very much
so long thanks a lot for having us
[Music]
you